the cmt music awards were handed out
last night and not only did the
performances go beyond the country music
genre
so did the winners yeah it's incredible
john legend won his first cmt award
i don't know where that fits into the
whole egot thing but like yeah out
he won video of the year along with
carrie underwood for their duet
hallelujah
her perform with chris stapleton mickey
guyton was joined
by breeland and gladys knight and kelsey
ballerini
one for her collaboration with halsey
i think especially the audience that
watches cnts
are really accepting of people
collaborating and pushing boundaries and
just
taking artistic risks and blending
genre lines i think it's a really
exciting time and um
i've always loved being at the full part
of that and so to see the people
not only tolerate it but celebrate it
very good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
john legend thank you for sending me
this incredible song
and agreeing to sing with me on it and
making this incredible
um video which i'm so proud of and
congratulations on what i think is your
first cmt award
[Music]
i gotta prove i'm wrong
cause i know it's okay to be in my own
lane
when i'm doing what they say can't be
done
i'm going across touch i will stop
running
your
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um and he says no aaron names is carrie
underwood's first cmt word no it's john
legend's first cmt award and someone
else asked did johnny go country it
wasn't really a country song it's for
her christmas album
it's a very piano bass song but yeah
it's the first time he's won video of
the year
um there and then what was the other
comment oh say it uh sanders says
probably the worst cmt show ever sorry
wow so that's a downer so can you what
do you think of it like
obviously we talked about diversity at
the country musical awards shows like
this is like full out
like almost every number was something
different
yeah um wow her and chris stapleton
oh my god brought me to tears listen
i've always felt like just as a
singer and a musician always felt like
country music
just lives in its own bubble the same
way that r b lives in its own bubble and
it kind of is insane to me because you
know some of the greatest country
singers and some of the greatest r b
singers
have so much soul in their voice there's
there's a lot of similarities
to their style of singing um that it
makes sense for the gender lines to get
blurred for a show like this
it was beautiful to see these are some
of the best singers
it doesn't even need to be about color
or you know genre or anything it's
really about
these incredible musicians these
incredible singers coming together and
giving the fans something beautiful
i i don't know i haven't watched every
cmt
i haven't watched all of them be honest
with you so i don't know the comparison
each award
show but i have to say like this was
enjoyable for me
it felt fresh and new and every every
moment was like i didn't know what to
expect and i feel like that's what an
award show
about you know i know the scene way of
big things but
even when you look at the grammys um
there's so much mixing of culture and
and genres
that you never know who's gonna get put
together even just to
to um i thought it was cool i thought
cmt
you know spiced it up i'd like to know
why that comment um
was made by it was it sandra why was
this the worst
one ever if she can expand on that
[Music]
i mean that that could just be based
around the fact that her favorite artist
didn't win
uh i will say this if you are a country
fan you are spoiled with talent right
now
like absolutely spoiled with talent
right now
um countries really gone through a lot
and i remember
not that long ago when they had to
determine
within their own community what was
country when little nausax and billy ray
cyrus put them in a position to
have to sort of put a label on what is
and what isn't country
and their decisions at the time didn't
go over well and the evolution
especially when you look at that stage
last night they have evolved as a
community
and as a collective of artists faster
than i would say any other branch in
entertainment has
and if you had put money on who was
going to be the fastest to change
and who was going to be the last to
adapt i think a lot of people would have
bet against country music
um but the talent on that stage and i'm
with you keisha
her and chris stapleton was like so
glorious
and man if you are a fan of country you
right now are
you are spoiled with talent
yeah tesco says why i liked it um tony
says it looks like a block party
people are pointing out how amazing
gladys knight looks she's 78
yesterday's 78 yeah like she's like 30
years old
yeah she looked absolutely amazing know
what they say
i
fulani says country music and r b music
both originated from gospel music it was
producers who segregated
um the genre yeah i mean we've seen this
over i don't remember what country music
awards shows
it was but remember we saw like meghan
trainor on one time with sonic jonas on
one time we said justin timberlake and
chris stapleton's not together
the big one that caused the most
conversation was beyonce
and the chicks that's the one that
people always go back to that literally
had country music stars
walking out of the room which is just
ridiculous but yeah it's slowly getting
there i still think the sad thing is
that all the country music award shows
now seem to be very conscious of
diversity across
like gender and race but country radio
is still
stuck in whatever decade you want to say
they're still only playing white men so
the fact that we're seeing all this
diversity in the award shows it's not
what's happening
in country radio so i don't know what
it's going to take for these guys to
head up these radio stations to finally
start playing some of these artists but
yeah they
even females they only basically play
carrie underwood and miranda lambert and
maybe mary morris a little bit so
yeah it's great to see this diversity in
award shows but it's still translating
to radio and that's where it really
matters in terms of
sales obviously these award shows have
millions of viewers but yeah on a
day-to-day basis
these artists are not getting like
mickey gaiden and brilliant are getting
the play that
uh luke bryan or jason dean gets
yeah i mean if you look at like music
programmers no i was gonna say i didn't
know if ross was gonna chime in
because because of the radio background
but i just in my experience with music
programmers at radio stations
they're usually older and they've been
there for a really
long time just from what i've seen so a
lot of times like
creating a change is is gonna take a lot
more like
they're gonna have to get a programmer i
think that's what the issue is for me in
my
in my opinion with radio making changes
in country music
yeah and and the the reluctance is uh
based usually around two things
one um the amount of research that they
do with regards to their audience and a
lot of this is based on what the
the audience wants as opposed to the way
that they want to program
and uh radio is and has always been
especially mainstream radio country
radio um
they're very reluctant you would think
that radio would be the first you would
hear a song from a new artist
it's not um it's one of the last places
you would hear um
everything you make money when the songs
are familiar
you don't make money the philosophy you
don't make money
on on new music on new artists and
that's why
you know it seems like it's so
incredibly slow
um but they they're not on new artists
and they you know it's
they never have been yeah hopefully that
changes